my bag yes oh my God finally some relief
after what has been an incredibly bumpy
Journey for newlyweds Nikita Reese
Wilson and her husband the couple
enjoyed a honeymoon in Greece last fall
but like many they returned home without
any luggage we did our due diligence we
filled out all the paperwork we filed a
missing baggage and now this is at its
facility the couple tracked their
baggage with air tags they watched as it
sat in Montreal for roughly a month
before being shipped out to a facility
in Etobicoke and we got really excited
because we were like oh it's coming back
to Toronto maybe it's going to be like a
processing facility we're gonna get our
bag this is awesome but their suitcases
remained there for more than three
months they called Air Canada countless
times no luck that's when they got the
police involved officers searched the
Etobicoke facility after they did the
investigation Air Canada then said it
was owned by charity we don't know that
charity name it's on the police report
which we haven't gotten yet
so now we're like why was our bag
wrongfully donated after 31 days to
Charities all our Canada was willing to
tell Global News was that it was working
to resolve the ordeal
has a name it's called theft this is the
most egregious baggage related issue I
have seen in my 15 years of being a
passenger rights Advocate meanwhile
Toronto police say it is not a criminal
matter and that they are no longer
investigating but legal experts are
raising concerns about the airline's
current lost luggage practices it's not
lawfully in possession of that bag it
was delayed
now lost and now found it hasn't been
signed over to Air Canada at any point
thank you well the couple has since been
reunited with their possessions Reese
Wilson says her experience can happen to
anyone and encourages people to hold
Airlines accountable Brittany Rosen
Global News